hi there I'm Samuel from simply lund and
let me help you understand about AWS ec2
a compute service in the cloud through
this video somewhere far in the country
a scientist has a lab far in the woods
and at one day he stumbled on a
calculation that he had trouble solving
and he was very certain that his
computer can handle it
and he asked his computer to do the math
or the calculation for him and the
computer thought about it for a while
then took a couple of hours in trying to
process the data and eventually at one
point it gave up and died due to low
memory and this old scientist is now
clueless about how he was going to
finish the task and complete his
invention and let the whole world know
about it and that's when he was
introduced to this new friend AWS as you
see on the screen
AWS was very handy in replacing his old
machines and it was able to give him the
service that he wanted at that moment
AWS has been around for a while helping
people with their computer needs and now
this new scientist friend in need is
welcomed by the new and trendy ID
technology AWS and sure enough his new
arable his friend
welcomed and walked him through the new
way of computing and this new happy
faced a table his friend talked to this
scientist about AWS ec2 in specific and
walked him through about all the new
innovations in IT and in cloud that he
had been missing all these days so his
new friend
AWS started the conversation about
explaining how there is no need for any
hardware units no managing hardware or
provisioning in AWS and secondly it
explained increasing and decreasing the
capacity as per the demand is just a
click away and the best part here is
that there is no upfront commitment and
we only pay for what we have used just
like we pay electricity and water bills
and all this comes with complete control
from our side other words the whole key
for this infrastructure is with us and
as if this was not enough all this comes
with enterprise-grade security that's
beyond imagination in on-premises and if
this still does not excite you
than this definitely would you can work
from anywhere in the world now this
really made the scientist to get excited
especially when he thought about working
from home working from home there is
nothing like it isn't it now this person
the scientist is not tied up to a
particular environment he can work from
home work on the fly work from anywhere
still the data and everything else in
his IT environment is secure and safe
now let's move to the next level of
discussion let's talk about what is easy
too and some of the use cases of ec2 and
this use case we're gonna talk about are
this architecture we're gonna talk about
it notifies a group of users about a new
letter and the components our resources
this architecture would need the first
ec2 instance their SNS a simple
notification service and coupling ec2
and s3 service together that's all it
would require to get an architecture
that notifies a group of users about a
new newsletter and now I think it would
be a good time to talk about what easy
do is AWS offers plenty of services
offered under different domains like in
a compute storage database migration
network management tools media services
security business productivity
application integration a machine
learning game development and lot more
coming up out of which easy do falls
under the compute capacity so what is
easy - easy - is a web service which
aims to make life easier for developers
for providing secure and a resettable
compute capacity in the cloud with ec2
it is very easy to scale up or scale
down our infrastructure based on the
demand and not only that this ec2
service can be integrated well with
almost all the services in Amazon and
out of all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use alright
let's talk about this use case a use
case here is that a successful business
owner has a bunch of users and a
successful product that's running and
now he has developed a few more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are gonna
like now
how can he advertise his product to his
new and prospective customers or the
solution for this question can be
addressed by AWS in AWS we can use
services like simple notification
service SNS and ec2 for compute and s3
for storage we can in a way integrate
them all and achieve this business use
case and that sort of god this business
owner very cheered up and now he wants
to use the service and he wants to get
benefited from the service he wants to
advertise or he wants to notify his
users every time the company creates a
newsletter all right so let's talk about
what it would take to get this
environment up and running or what it
would take to connect the environment
and put the applications on top of it
firstly we would require an AWS account
and then for compute capacity we would
require an ec2 instance and here's how
we go about doing it the first thing is
to create an ami which is Amazon mission
image that's really the software's and
the application packages we would need
to run our application and the second is
to choose the hardware in here it's the
instance type depending on the workload
we would be choosing the hardware and
depending on the intense of the workload
we will be choosing the size of the
hardware and finally we would configure
the instances in a how many instance do
I want you know which subnet do I want
them in and what's going to be the in a
stop or terminate behavior of the
instance and do I want to update any
patches when the instance starts running
all those pieces of information going
here when we configure the instance and
then the first three steps is really
about the OS volume and the basic
hardware now it's time to add additional
storage to the ec2 instance that would
be step four here
we add additional storage to the ec2
instance and then tags we use tags or we
would configure tags to easily identify
an ec2 instance at a later point you
know we give it some meaningful names so
we can identify like you know which team
it belongs to which billing department
it belongs to what's the purpose behind
launch
instance stuff like that in an
environment where we run 700 to 800 or
even more instances identifying an
instance and trying to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be n
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging a step
six we would configure the firewall
which is also called a security group
for the ec2 instance and this is where
we would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways from
outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and IP address and finally a
step seven we review all the
configurations that you have done and we
make sure that the configurations is
what we wanted and finally click on
summit that's going to launch an ec2
instance alright this was just an
overview of how to create an ec2
instance now let's talk about each and
every step in detail so to begin with
let's talk about how to create an ami
well the ami is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an a new computer or a new
VM or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that
the ami will also contain software
information you know information about
operating system information about
access permission information about
volumes they all compact in the AMI
again the ami is of two types one is
predefined a mice or called Amazon
provided a mice the other one would be
customized to a mice that we create and
if you're looking at a particular ami
that you don't want to create but still
want to get it from Amazon there is a
place or a portal called a my
marketplace there we get like thousands
of a.m. ice in there available for us to
shop and use them on a pay-as-you-go
business model and use them as
pay-as-you-go billing so there you can
search a mind that you're looking for
most probably you'll be able to get it
there now let's talk about choosing the
instance type the instance type is
basically the hardware specification
that's required for a machine that we're
trying to build and the instant types is
categorized into five main families they
are to begin with it's computer
optimized now computer optimized gives
us lots of compute power or lots of
processing power so if my application is
gonna require a lot of processing power
I should be picking computer optimized
instance and the second one is memory
optimized now this is very good for
applications that require in-memory
caching you know there are some
application that performs well with
cache or through cache or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in cash for a
rereading or for processing you know for
lengthy processing stuff like that for
those type of application this memory
optimized instance that comes with
in-memory cache is a very good use case
and the third one is the instant that
comes with GPU otherwise called GPU
optimized GPU stands for graphical
process unit and this is very good for
application that deals with gaming this
is very good for application that's
gonna require large graphical
requirements and storage optimized is
the fourth option just like the name
says this is very good use case for
storage servers and the fifth family
type is general-purpose just like the
name says it's for general purpose if
you're not particular about the family
then you generally would end up picking
the general purpose because here the
services are sort of equally balanced
you know you'll find a balance between
the virtual CPU and the memory and the
storage and the network performance it's
sort of balanced all the components all
the features that needs to go in a
computer are sort of balanced in general
purpose now these instant types are
fixed and they cannot be altered because
it's hardware based we buy hardware we
do not have much control on the hardware
that's being used well we have options
but we do not have control on the
hardware and these instant types are
divided into five main families they are
computer optimized memory optimized GPU
enabled storage optimized and
general-purpose then as third thing or
we have to configure the instance now
here is where I have a lot of options
about purchasing you know what type of
purchasing do I want to do do I want to
go for a spot instance do I want to go
for a reserved instance do I want to go
for an on-demand instance these are
different billing options available and
that's available under configure
instance not only that here's where I'm
gonna put the ec2 instance do I want and
public I Peters assigned to it do I want
and I am role attached to it I am role
is authentication or what kind of
authentication am I gonna provide and
the shadown behavior the Sherin
behaviors include do I want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do I want to
simply terminate the inst instance when
the user shuts down the instance from
the desktop so those things go in here
just like the name says configure
instance a lot of instance configuration
options comes in here
that's the third step and not only that
under the advanced details or Advanced
tab under configure instance I can
bootstrap the instance with some scripts
now bootstrap is nothing but the scripts
that you want to be run in the instance
before it actually comes online let's
say you're provisioning the instance for
somebody else you know instead of you
launching the instance and then logging
in and running some commands and then
handing it over to the other person you
can create bootstrap shell scripts and
you know paste it in a console option
available under configure instance and
Amazon is gonna take those commands run
it on the instance before it hands over
to the user that initially requested for
that instance now it could be a
different user or just you it's sort of
automates you know software installation
procedures in the instance that we will
be launching and not only that there are
multiple payment options available under
configure instance the user can pick an
instance under normal price and that
instance would apply normal rates
applied to it and there are also options
like reserved instance where the user
can pay for an instance upfront
before a year or before months you know
for a span of year or a span of months
and that way they can pay less for our
for using that instance not only that
you can also go for spot instance like
bidding for those instances whoever bids
more they get the instance for that
particular time well these instances are
lot cheaper than on-demand instances and
through bidding and buying you can keep
the instance as long as your bid price
doesn't exceed the price that Amazon is
proposing and as the fourth step we will
have to add storage to the instance that
we are about to launch and here we have
a bunch of storage options I can go for
a Pomerol storage which is free or I can
go for an external elastic block storage
also called EBS which is paid and it's a
permanent storage or else I can
integrate my ec2 instance with s3 for
its storage needs and the best part
about storage is free subscription users
they get to use 30 gigabit of SSD
storage or magnetic storage for the
whole year in this page where we are
ready to add storage we will have to
mention or provide the size in gigabyte
and the volume type is it gonna be an
provision the volume is going to be an
general-purpose volume is it gonna be a
magnetic volume stuff like that
they are volume types and we also need
to give inputs about where the disk will
be mounted and whether this volume needs
to be encrypted or not so all these
options are all these inputs are
received from us under the adding
storage section and then the fifth
option would be adding tags like we
discussed sometime back tags are very
helpful to identify a machine in an
environment where we have seven hundred
or thousand VMs running and security
groups are the actual firewall that sits
in front of ec2 instance and it protects
that ec2 instance from unintended
inbound and outbound traffic now here is
where I can fine tune at the access to
my ec2 instance based on port numbers
and based on IP address from which it
can be accessed and finally we
to review the whole changes or the whole
configurations that we have made to find
out whether they are intact with the
requirement and then click on submit
that's going to launch an ec2 instance
but hold on we're not done yet when
we're about to launch or before the
Amazon console actually launches the ec2
instance it's gonna give us an option to
create a keeper I remember I said it's
keep air you know keep air is two things
one is public and private the private
key is downloaded by the user and is
kept with the user and the public key is
used by Amazon to confirm the identity
of the user so just go ahead and
download the private key and keep it for
yourself and this private key gets
downloaded as an dot PEM file it's a
format off the file and it gets
downloaded as dot PEM file and our next
step is to access the ec2 instance and
because the instance that we have
launched in this example let's assume
it's Linux instance and that's gonna
require a tool called putty to be able
to access it and this pootie tool is
really needed when we are trying to
access and Linux instance from windows
instance most of the time windows
instance will have put the installed in
them but in some rare cases they do not
come with putty in those cases we can go
ahead and download putty and put
regenerator and we can start using it to
access the Linux instance now you might
ask well I understand putti what's put
regenerator now the file that we have
downloaded is in dot Pam format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
Pam format as input you know it has to
be converted into a different format
called PPK and put it Jen is a tool that
helps us to convert the dot Pam file
into PPK file so the quick way to do it
is download generator open it up click
on conversion and insert the dot Pam key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and this when we save the
private key it gets saved as a dot PPK
type private key and when that's done
the next very step is to open pootie and
try to login and the way to login is to
open pootie put that I
Peter's here and then click on odd you
know this is where we would input the
file that we have created so click on up
and then click on browse and find the
dark PBK file that we have converted and
stored browse it and upload it and then
click on open now that's gonna open up a
login screen for us and the a.m. eyes
comes with a default username depending
on the ami that we have picked the
username might differ in our case we
have picked an ami for which the
username is easy to - user and this is
the default by the way let's put the
username ec2 - user and hit enter and
that's gonna open up the Linux instance
using CLI there are a few other things
that we can do with the terminal that
will explain it little later all right
so we have successfully launched an ec2
instance and yeah give yourself a pat on
your back launching an instance was just
one part of the solution
so let's actually talk about how we can
notify our customers SNS or simple
notification service is a service or a
product in Amazon that helps us to
notify customers through email so a
navigate to SNS in your account and
create a topic and we're going to use
this topic for public notification so
let's make it public and then add a
subscribers to it now these subscribers
these subscribers are the people who you
want to be notified about the newsletter
so if we already have the email database
in there add them to the subscribers
list and then they will start getting
new newsletters as and when we post them
to the topic and as next step create a
bucket in s3 we can store content and in
that bucket create an event that
triggers a notification to simple
notification service so this is how it
will be setup and notification will be
sent to our subscribers anytime we put
something in our s3 bucket so s3 bucket
is going to create an event for the
notification and the notification is
going to make sure that it's delivered
to your end customer because they're
already subscribed to the topic as a
subscriber
and finally let's connect the s3 with
ec2 so the bucket and the AWS instance
are in sync so we put some content in
the s3 bucket our email system notifies
our customers and the customers can go
online to a website that's hosted in ec2
and because s3 and ec2 are in sync the
items that we put an s3 will also show
up in easy to see how this is all
connected and it's working together and
once this is all connected our
subscribers will regularly be informed
anytime we put new content in the s3
bucket and the same content will be made
available in ec2 instance through the
website so what did we learn we learned
about how easy to can replace the
hardware system for computing and we can
go watch oh where we don't have to
manage anything and also the environment
is scalable in a couple of button clicks
and it also provides pay as we go type
of subscription and not only that we
have full control of the environment and
it's highly secure at the same time and
then we learned about what ec2 is what
EC do can do and how well it integrates
with other services in Amazon we also
looked at in detail about how to
provision an ec2 instance a step-by-step
approach and finally we talked about a
use case finally we talked about a use
case where a business owner wants to
notify his users about the new product
that he is developing and anytime that's
available he wanted an email to go out
to the customer notifying about the new
product and the customers can come
online and check it on the ec2 instance
that he was running all right I believe
that was a good amount of explanation
about what easy doest and how it gets
connected how to provision and how to go
about building an architecture like we
saw I believe you enjoy the session I'll
meet you in another session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here